Hello, Andrea.
Good afternoon, Andrea.
You're on YouTube, you're speaking.
Yeah.
Still can't hear you, still showing on mute.
How about this? Is this better?
Yeah, yeah, now we can hear you.
Okay, great. I couldn't get it to switch off.
Yeah.
All time, Andrea, how are you doing?
Oops, looks like your bike's working.
You're back on mute.
Yes.
I don't know why that keeps happening. Okay, do you hear me now?
Yes, we can hear now.
Yep, we can.
Yes, good. Okay, good.
So, how have you been?
So, how was the Kour?
Pardon?
Just seeing how, how are you doing?
Oh, I'm doing fine, thank you.
Great. And you had the long weekend, so did you do something, I mean, out of the world?
Yeah, I did a lot of holiday things. We had fireworks, and we had a parade, and I went to the beach twice, and I went to a BBQ, and my sister came to visit, so it was a big weekend.
Uh-huh.
No.
Nice.
I was going through a news article, I guess, because of the fireworks. I think the air quality has deteriorated a bit.
Yep.
Yes, that's true. I read the same thing. I think also because people were having bonfires, that that contributed to that. I'm not a big fan of the bonfires.
Um...
Yeah.
Kip.
I'm very pro-environment.
That's great. I know you go for a walk during your lunch break, so I remember that you told me once.
Now.
I do. And after supper too. Whenever possible, even in bad weather.
Well, but...
That's a good habit, you know. It keeps your system clean and functional.
Yes.
both mentally and physically.
Absolutely.
And you also like warm weather, right? Summers?
I beg your pardon?
And you also like summers, not winters?
I do, I do, very much so.
No.
Yeah.
So I don't think Kris will be joining us. He has another meeting, so it will just be us. But it's nice to see you, Ash. I haven't seen you in many months now.
Okay.
Yeah, I deliberately jumped out of this call because I wanted to say hi to you.
Oh, that's nice. I appreciate it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
So how are things going with Sameer?
I think that they're going very well. She's doing a great job.
Hello?
Something I had a little bit of an issue with but has cleared up is prioritizing tickets. When I give her a nice list of tickets and I told her to always follow from the first one down to the last one and she does that just fine.
But every once in a while, we'll have something kind of urgent. And I'll give it to her and say, oh, can you please help so-and-so? And she was tending to keep on working her list the way it was and then adding them to the bottom. So I have begun saying, you know, this is urgent or this is immediate or this person needs help right away.
Mhm.
to let her know that and that seems to be working well.
Okay. Okay.
Apart from this, anything else maybe from Kris?
He hasn't said anything, so I think no news is good news on his part.
OK.
Okay.
But he's been tied up with other projects too, so I've basically been the only person interacting with Sameer.
And, uh, Andrea, is Nick still working with Pre Swati?
Yes, he is. He was on vacation, but he is still with us.
Okay, that's great. So is he still involved with the field work or does he interact with?
Yeah.
Yeah, he's been going a lot of on-site things.
On site.
Okay, yeah.
I was just recalling.
He was he was on site last week, and he'll be going on site again this Wednesday.
OK, that's great. I hope he's also doing good.
And.
Yes, he is.
Alright, well, Kip over to you.
Yeah, okay, so let's jump into the VPT then and let's review some range performance for the last two weeks. Let me share my screen real quick.
Okay.
Let me know once you're able to see.
I can see it.
Okay, great. So once again, welcome to our bi-weekly business review. This is for the last two weeks, starting June 22nd till July 3rd.
No change in the agenda. We will start with check-in with highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward, and recap.
And we already talked about how things are moving and thank you for sharing the feedback for somebody.
Yeah, we really appreciate it.
Moving on to the highlights, so we have been getting positive feedback for Sameer. She's capable, pleasant, and reliable. And also, she's getting appreciated for her strong ticket notes and documentation. And I believe she is still following when she's stuck. She's
Reaching out to Kris.
Yes, she actually had one this morning and she reached out to him for some help with it.
That's great, that's great. Regarding the KPI reporting set up in Autotask, I mean, I've been working with Kaseya Support and...
Their account manager is trying to reach Kris. So Naomi, I believe she's the account manager and she's trying to reach Kris. But Kris maybe, as you said, that he's busy on some projects. So he has not yet replied, but we are still on track.
Okay.
Right.
For this.
Okay.
Yeah, so once we have the access to the database, we will start setting up the reportings in Autotask. And regarding the CSAT, the CSAT survey for some rain is pending for the month of May and June.
OK.
Okay.
I did send an e-mail to Kris. Yeah, I will send him in a follow up e-mail on the same.
You should remind again. Yeah.
Yeah.
So regarding the action, yeah.
So on survey piece, Andrea, do you think if we can also add you as the recipient of the C search service?
Um, I don't know. You'd have to ask Kris if he would want to hand that off to me.
Pre.
Yeah, sure, we can we can check with Kris, but the reason why I asked is because you more often work with Sameer and Kris, you know, always being busy, so we would also don't want to reach out to him every month to get the C-cell service. So, since we are meeting bi-weekly over Sameer, you call.
Correct.
And you are regular to these calls, so you know, just coming from that from that point of view, if you could let us know your feedback about the same, we can check this with Kris.
Sure, I agree that it's a smart idea, but I would have to get approval first.
OK, sure, I understand.
I agree. I respect that and we'll check with Kris on this.
Okay.
Yep.
Thank you.
All right, so moving on to the action tracker. Again, the first one, KPI reports. That's again, we are awaiting update from Kaseya Support. And level up to advanced system administrator. So this is completed. So some rain has been
Mhm.
Promoted to advanced system administrator in ITBD.
OK, good.
Yeah.
And moving on to the KPIs part, that again we already discussed with Kris, so let's skip this and let's jump into the performance analysis.
This is our utilization for the last two weeks. First week, 53%, and then in the last week it was 50. On an average, it was 51%. A little low on the second week was due to the long weekend.
Mhm.
That's one of the reasons. Any question on this?
Yeah, a lot of people are on vacation these two weeks, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That looks fine.
Okay, and moving on to the ticket data, this is also, you can see it's completely aligned with the utilization part. The first one, in the first week, she worked on 54 tickets, and in the second, she worked on 37. That's again due to the long weekend. So in total, she worked on 91 tickets and closed 44.
And that makes her average closure to forty-eight percent.
Okay.
Way forward, again, this is, we are keeping a close eye to somebody to reach out to Kris sooner whenever she's stuck on any issue, and I believe she's following the same, and also maintain detailed ticket time entries.
Yes.
which Kris specifically requested and continue proactive escalations. And we will continue to support her to close more tickets.
Haight.
This is the AI Build it Live, which the session that we are having from August 3rd till 5. The details for this has already been shared with Kris, and I believe Kris is out somewhere during that time.
He's out of the country, yes, on vacation.
Yeah, on vacation. OK.
So, okay, this is AI by design. Again, already, Kris is already aware of this. We already shared the details. And this is the Team GPS, our in-house tool for managing the performance. And that's it.
Okay.
So anything apart from this you want to share, suggest, any feedback?
I think that covers it.
Okay.
All right, any question from you, Ashish?
No, I don't have any questions. It was nice meeting you, Andrea. Thank you so much for your valuable contribution so far. Appreciate it.
Yes, nice seeing you.
Sure. Always hope to be.
So thank you, Andrea. Thank you for joining the call and have a wonderful rest of the day and week.
Thank you.
Okay, I wish the same to you.
Yep, thank you. Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Okay, bye.